this will not be quick this is a
long-term campaign
isil is opportunistic and it is nimble
in many places in syria and iraq
including urban areas
it's dug in among innocent civilian
populations
it will take time to root them out
and doing so must be the job of local
forces on the ground
with training and air support from our
coalition
as with any military effort there will
be periods of progress
but there are also going to be some
setbacks as we've seen with isil's gains
in ramadi in iraq
and central and southern syria but today
it's also important for us to recognize
the progress that's been made our
coalitions now hit isil with more than
5 000 airstrikes we've taken out
thousands
of fighting positions tanks vehicles
bomb factories
and training camps we've eliminated
thousands of fighters
including senior isil commanders and
over the past year we've seen that when
we have an effective partner on the
ground
isil can be pushed back
in iraq isil lost at the mosul dam
isil lost at mount sinjar isil has lost
repeatedly
across kirkuk province isil lost
at tikrit altogether isil has lost more
than a quarter of the populated areas
that it had seized in iraq
in syria isil lost to kobani
it's recently endured losses across
northern syria including the key city of
talib denying isil a vital supply route
to
raqqa its base of operations in
syria so these are reminders that isil's
strategic
weaknesses are real isil surrounded by
countries and communities
committed to its destruction it has no
air force
our coalition owns the skies isil is
backed by no nation
it relies on fear sometimes executing
its own disillusioned fighters
its unrestrained brutality often
alienates those under its rule
creating new enemies in short isil's
recent losses in both syria and iraq
prove that isil can
and will be defeated indeed
we're intensifying our efforts against
isil's base in syria
our airstrikes will continue to target
the oil and gas facilities
that fund so much of their operations
we're going after the
isil leadership and infrastructure in
syria
the heart of isil that pumps funds and
propaganda to
people around the world partnering with
other countries
sharing more information strengthening
laws and border security
allows us to work to stem the flow of
foreign fighters to syria
as well as iraq and to stem
obviously the flow of those fighters
back into our own countries
this continues to be a challenge and
working together all nations are going
to need to do more
but we're starting to see some progress